all right i want to show you another one
of these really dumb gas prices
conversations and i'm so sick of this
stuff and unfortunately sometimes the
left does it as well um former new
orleans mayor mitch landrieu is now a
senior advisor and infrastructure
coordinator to the biden administration
he went on fox news yesterday and was
interviewed by fox news host bret bayer
about gas prices and they basically just
got into pointing the finger at each
other
about the same game that both sides play
with gas prices and uh bret bayer says
delandrew you're giving joe biden credit
for the gas prices going down
but when they went up you said it was
vladimir putin and landrieu says to bret
bayer well you guys on fox news when the
gas prices went up you blame joe biden
and now that they go down you don't give
joe biden the credit and both are sort
of true and it's part of what makes this
all so very stupid things quickly one is
that you mentioned that the president
you're giving the president credit for
the gas prices going down but when they
went up it was vladimir putin and the
ukraine war well we could say it another
way when it went up you guys accused him
for making it happen and when it went
down you forgot to give him credit for
it and so well he started going before
right it actually started going up
before biden was even president right i
mean that that's the funny thing about
it which is if you the the game that
brett bayer wants to play
is one that ignores
that the gas prices were actually going
up under trump as well and in fact i
believe i have the chart here which i
can show you
um and if you take a look at this chart
let's look at the
yeah here it is so if you look at this
um in at the bottom for gas prices was
like late april of 2020 so gas prices go
up
in june and then they go up
and up and up and up and so the what
happened was that there was a demand
collapsed during covid and then gas
prices started going up and then the
ukraine russia war and all these
different things and every country was
affected by it so brett bayer is playing
the exact same game here that they all
play but that that that is let me let me
say this too the other thing that's
happening is when when the price of
barrel goes up the price of gas goes up
and when it goes down it doesn't go down
and the president called that out and we
need to work on that too because it's
the american people that ought to
benefit okay yeah so you guys get the
point i mean i wish that they would just
follow my lead and say hey you know what
brett let's not play these games gas
prices are a global issue related to
global supply and only in a small way do
presidents make a difference on oil
price on gas prices and by the way in
the united states we have extremely
cheap gas compared to other countries in
the united states we don't accurately
price a gallon of gas to actually
reflect the true costs including the
environmental costs it's subsidized the
entire thing is a joke and you know if
it were me we should be moving to
electric vehicles but i know that that's
not exactly what they can say at every
opportunity but they're both
correctly
pointing to the fact that the other side
plays the exact same game abandon it do
what i've done since george w bush
gas prices up under bush doesn't really
have much to do with bush
gas prices down under bush doesn't
really have much to do with bush
although he actually did invade iraq
which at least has some connection to
oil that is more than what any other
president could could actually be um uh
could be attributed to other presidents
with obama when the gas prices were
extraordinarily low i said
it's nice i guess for drivers but it
doesn't really have anything to do with
barack obama same thing under trump and
this is what you get nobody wins from
this conversation they each try to make
their political point they each try to
say the other side is playing a
political game and they're all it's all
true they're all doing it but we learn
absolutely nothing one of our sponsors
is imme
hands down some of the best ramen
noodles i've had just like any instant
ramen you pop emmy into the microwave or
on the stovetop for a few minutes and
it's ready to go but what makes me
different is that it is packed with 21
grams of protein lower in sodium 100
percent plant-based with 18 grams of
fiber for digestive health and it tastes
excellent
so many of the other ramens are bland
simple artificial imi uses high quality
ingredients and recipes you get a zing
of flavor i've never had with any
instant ramen emmy comes in amazing
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp and black garlic chicken
if you try emmy and don't love it
you get your money back you'll get five
dollars off when you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below